the situation unfolding in ukraine many
are wondering how the conflict is
affecting their wallets their finances
brian is talking with financial expert
in studio tonight looking to get you
some answers brian denise we do have
that expert live in studio we're talking
with russell price senior vp of mpi
wealth management ubs russell thank you
for being here thanks for having me
brian first market correction in some 21
months when you combine the double
whammy of inflation and the war in
ukraine what can people expect in terms
of nuts and bolts with the market over
the next weeks and months
well when you when you look at what
we've had in 2022 it's been real
challenging for investors right we
started out covet 19 still concerned
about spike in that we then talked about
inflation the fed raising interest rates
and then we were hit with the russian
ukraine uh conflict
what the first thing that we always look
at is how diversified and right now
investors understand if they're
diversified or not right what kind of
impact do they have do they have
different asset styles in their
portfolio great example asset styles
would be
value versus growth values down as of
friday was down about five percent where
growth is down about 15 percent
so you really can start to look at a
lack of diversification in the portfolio
and that's probably the first thing you
should do to improve for the upcoming
market experts like yourself look at
every scenario if there is a situation
where china invades taiwan or if russia
went somehow into a nato country that's
going to increase volatility but if that
doesn't happen if the conflict stays
within ukraine if there are brighter
days ahead there
what can we expect in terms of recovery
we have we have seen today the united
states may weather this a little better
than expected yeah i think that the
recovery starts with the diversification
right how deep of a hole are you in uh
the second part is selecting certain
sectors that you expect to do well
whether that is the financial sector
where rates rising those tend to do well
uh banks in in in in that sector you can
also look at possibly adding energy
stocks right we even even though energy
stocks have had a a huge run-up talk
about a negative market energy stocks
are up 22 this year uh so so you can
still put some of that in the portfolio
that will allow you to participate with
the upside still have some some downside
protection looking at energy uh defense
technology some of the things that could
go up what about the person watching
just going wait a second a lot of cyber
warfare with russia what if they hit our
banks hypothetically how much cash
should i have on hand what do you
recommend people to just have a little
more money aside yeah i think before
diversification you have to look at what
type of planning you put in your
portfolio so what a lot of what we do is
we look at three segments of a portfolio
and we put those into those different
segments or three buckets if you will
the first is the liquidity bucket for
individual that is retired perhaps
that's a year's worth of income that's
in that budget is that right perhaps
there's you know that you want to buy a
house so that's in that bucket so
emotionally that's a much better
conversation to have with your advisor
with yourself that you have a year's
worth of spending
and you don't have to worry about those
ups and downs in the market day-to-day
we have to wrap here but a very quick
answer on this how much will the covid
recovery that's already happened the
fact that we're coming down so much from
omicron how much will that help moving
forward economically
it's it's going to be a big help it's
going to be a big help with inflation as
the spin the dollars that we spend as
consumers goes away from goods and into
service and hopefully vegas will uh
participate in that and have a lot more
good upcoming months okay those tourists
are coming back we appreciate your
expertise thank you so much russell
price with
ubs we're going to check in now with
denise and ted